je
salut à tous ce dimanche matin dans
l'ouest pour vous parler d'un sport qui
compte plus de 450 licenciés plus d'une
vingtaine de sportifs réunionnais qui
nous représente sur plan mondial et pour
nous en parler fabrice fridmann alors ta
discipline c'est quoi le surf c'est
parti
fabrice est un acteur majeur du surf
réunionnais représentant de ligue
entraîneurs et surtout passionné moi mon
père m'a initié à au surf à l'âge de 10
ans eh ben je n'ai pas le goût du sel la
mer les couleurs la vitesse c'est un peu
comme une c'est une addiction dont on
devient accro ça et puis on peut plus
s'en passer et on rêve qu'une chose
c'est d'aller plus loin d'aller au large
de prendre un peu plus grosse un peu
plus belle
le saint leu surf club est une
association d'une centaine d'adhérents
kiev pour objectif le perfectionnement
un groupe de passionnés qui fait bouger
leur sport
tu sais
à peine arrivé l'impatience se fait
sentir trouver le bon spot en toute
sécurité reste l'objectif
pour anne un peu le spot et les vagues
s'ils voulaient parce qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de séries on concevait cheville
droite heavy rotation
à peine les consignes ont été données
que les marmailles ont foncé alors
foriic l'idée simple pratique et au
maximum c'est comme ça que le métier
rentre
m
c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui on a un
protocole qui est assez l'eau à mettre
en place pour une association
mais on a essayé d'y répondre au mieux
on a produit un protocole aujourd'hui on
avait deux à trois vigiles et dans l'eau
c'est le seul moyen pour que marc mahy
pratique pour que le marmaille puisse
passer quelques secondes debout sur une
planche de surf parce que vous faire à
un moment donné à partir des bases ou
faire du haut niveau eh bien il faut
passer du temps de ben est debout sur la
planche c'est pour cela que certains de
ces athlètes ont passé à au moins en
australie et se prépare à partir pour la
métropole
comment il fait partie quand même d'une
des dernières générations justement de
haut niveau sportif à la réunion et
oui le contexte actuel fait que c'est
quand même c'est quand même compliqué
puisque auparavant ont surfé autant il
ya une porte qui héberge et c'est vrai
que ça fait deux ans et demi où ça
devient très très compliqué déjà le
pouvoir la sortir effectivement de la
réunion de temps en temps ça permet
justement ne pas perdre ce niveau c'est
quoi la suite en avril je pars en france
pendant sept mois je vais faire des
compétitions et je perds ce que j'avais
à france comment
attends pas de l'énergie avec la vague y
en aura pas c'est toi qui crée belle
énergie